now the latest on the once soaring gas
prices that are falling fast this
morning the average nationwide cost for
a gallon of regular is about one dollar
cheaper than it was just in mid-june
when gas prices peaked it's a sign that
overall inflation may have peaked as
well errol barnett is at a gas station
in alexandria virginia just outside
washington errol good morning what are
you hearing from drivers there
hey there nancy good morning great to
see you and everyone well i can tell you
that this is typically a place of stress
and anxiety for most americans right
these days the vibe is much more calm
but it also is relative a regular gallon
of gas is one dollar more expensive than
a year ago but a dollar less expensive
than two months ago which has some folks
wondering if it's time for one last
summer road trip
finally a little less pain at the pump
i'm thrilled it's a miracle this gas
station in oklahoma was the first in the
country this year to sell fuel for less
than three dollars that's according to
gas buddy the fuel data website but
drivers everywhere are getting relief
just to be under four
i had to make sure to stop after a
summer fueled by inflation gas buddy
says this good news could continue we
could see the national average falling
another 15 to 30 cents a gallon and for
drivers once worried about cost there's
a new concern crowds returning to the
roads at the end of the summer americans
have either planned their summer travels
or they've carried them out already i
don't know that there will be a
meaningful increase in demand from the
fallen prices road trips are now cheaper
the savings on a drive from new york
city to niagara falls for example could
buy you a beer compared to what it would
have cost memorial day weekend the trek
from la to lake tahoe will save you
almost 10 bucks which could pump more
fuel into the economy when everything
kind of dies it starts to go back down
it's usually good to
put money back into the economy so i'll
probably start spending again
now this downward trend could be
reversed through any one number of
variables analysts for example point to
hurricane season which could disrupt oil
production in the gulf sending prices
even higher so to adapt another saying
nate fill them if you got them
that's right gas up those minivans and
suvs it's time for one more family road
trip errol thank you